when you get bothered you're going to
get more insults cuzz you give you gave
them what they wanted you gave that
reaction it worked bro nothing better
than smil and laugh it off like carry on
dud don't get mad don't let your ego get
to you and look there's nothing better
than actual
confidence right be like oh yeah you're
right I am kind of a knuckle dragger you
know how many times I've said that in my
life oh yeah I'm definitely Meathead for
sure yep like like just cool someone's
trying to insult me by calling me a
knuckle you freaking knuckle dragger
yeah definitely scraping them on the
floor like what you know what I mean
yeah yeah and they're right I am a
knuckle dragger so it's like cool like
what else right on